[Musique]
je suis allé sur internet et je nous ai
loué une magnifique maison sur la plage
je me suis dit qu'en réservant et en
faisant no valise ça éliminera sûrement
les chances que tu
[Musique]
refuses oh la grande
classe les enfants ont l'air tellement
heureux le Wii fonctionne
pas prends une
batte
[Musique]
pardonnez-moi de vous déranger mais vous
êtes dans notre
maison c'est votre
[Musique]
maison on était sur la route pour
rentrer chez nous et quelque chose s
produit vous voulez rester ici mais pour
l'instant c'est nous qui sommes là il
faut qu'on les fe
[Musique]
partir il faut qu'il cro que tout se
passera
bien mais tout pass bien de toute
façon
flash spécial nous sommes confrontés à
une cyberataque de grande ampleur à
travers tout le
pays il y a un truc pas normal et j'ai
pas confiance
en je vous ai dit absolument tout ce que
je
savais je ne vous crois pas je fer
n'importe quoi pour protéger ma famille
ce que vous faites de votre côté c'est
pas mon
problème
[Musique]
vous avez toujours pas remarqué ce qui
est en train de se
passer je sais pas ce qui se passe mais
ça nous implique
tous je veux seulement
savoir c'est quoi la
vérité